So let's look at some of the challenges
of computing depth from defocus.
One, it's extremely hard to discriminate
a scene where basically there
is smooth information or there is blur
information, specifically defocus blur.
And, of course, once we've figured
out if there is defocus blur,
it's hard to actually undo it.
So here basically again is example,
how do we know this is out of focus?
Again, by looking at it we
can kind of see it's blurry.
And how do we know what
kind of blur it is?
Remember when we talked about cameras,
blurry images can be caused by a variety
of reasons, this could have been
a blur because the camera shook.
How do we know it's actually a blur
because of it's out of focus, or
the focus plane is in front of or
behind it.
Another part of it is,
how to get rid of blur.
Well, there is a vast amount of
literature in image processing.
So if somebody gave you an image like
this, you can actually run an algorithm,
specifically the
Lucy-Richardson Algorithm,
which again has been know since 1972,
74.
Which would actually deconvolve this
image to be able to generate a sharper,
or attempt to create a sharper image.
But of course, if you notice here
there is an artifact called ringing,
you can see different types of
things across the five and the four.
This is an artifact that would come
in because we're trying to take this
information and
use that to sharpen an image.
And after certain kinds of sharpening
effects you'll actually get
artifacts like this.
Part of the reason is, again, if you
have an original image that's blurry
like this, you really can't completely
generate something out of nothing.
There's no information,
you can't create it.
One of the mantras always used
in computational photography is,
what you see is all you get.
That basically reduces the space
of what you can do with an image.
If you actually have a bad image
there are other ways you can try to
perfect it.
And we'll actually talk about
those types of things, too.